bienvenue bienvenue à tous paris saclay
télé se met au vert en ce début d'année
nous allons vous faire découvrir le
jardinage du futur avec cultive cette
start up a remporté le paris saclay
invest qui s'est déroulée ici h c'était
au mois de décembre
notre équipe était sur place et vous
l'avez peut-être remarqué l'agriculture
urbaine se développe sur votre
territoire un projet étonnant a germé au
sein du proto 204 il s'agit du green lab
vous pouvez tous y participer nous
allons vous expliquer comment
voilà qui ne devrait pas déplaire à
valérie masson-delmotte cette
climatologue citoyenne a participé à la
coop 21
elle nous fera part de son expérience et
enfin bonne nouvelle la première
résidence étudiante du campus paris
saclay va voir le jour
une opération ambitieuse avec 330
logements deux restaurants et une
multitude de commerces et enfin notre
agenda
ce sera à la fin de cette émission c'est
donc ici h c'est que s'est tenue le
paris saclay invest 2015 un rendez vous
devenu semestriel qui permet à de jeunes
entreprises innovantes de rencontrer des
investisseurs et le vainqueur de cette
deuxième édition et cultive cette start
up a imaginé le jardinage du futur
regardez
on sort aujourd'hui à paris saclay
invest c'est notre première
participation ici et on ici pour
présenter cultive donc cultive c'est
donc c'est une start up qui va permettre
en fait aux particuliers de reproduire
chez lui des fruits et des légumes frais
directement dans sa cuisine avec notre
premier produit c'est basile qui permet
de faire pousser en fait des herbes
aromatiques directement sur le plan de
travail de la cuisine et sans effort on
utilise des techniques un petit peu
particulière de culture sans terre un
éclairage led et dans un objet connecté
qui va vous permettre de vous rapprocher
un petit peu de la nature d'avoir des
conseils de jardinage des conseils de
cuisine et qui vous aider à réussir en
fait enfin vos tentatives de culture
aujourd'hui on a des naïve et superbe
retour ça fait vraiment plaisir en fait
de pitch est son projet on avait cinq
minutes pour le pitch est aujourd'hui
est de faire un petit peu de parcourir
la salle du regard et de voir des gens
qui acquiesce parce que c'est un sujet
en fait les traits qui est vraiment
d'actualité
on parle d'agriculture urbaine on parle
de faire soi même on parle de produits
ultra frais et on parle de cuisine alors
ça fait huit mois qu'on travaille à
temps plein avec mon associé à alexandre
et six mois qu'on travaille à l'usiné au
un atelier de prototypage dans paris où
on a pu produire donc ce prototype là
ainsi que ses 29 petits frères qui sont
en tête chez des particuliers
aujourd'hui et avec ses retours
d'expériences où on perfectionne notre
produit dans le but de l'industrialiser
demain et c'est la raison de notre
présence ici on est à la recherche du
financement pour l'industrialiser alors
en fait déjà nous comment on est arrivé
dans ce territoire
on a travaillé tous les deux pendant
pendant quatre ans avec alexandre et
ensuite j'ai fait un master spécialisé
entrepreneuriat donc qui était central
parier et
et avec l'essec vraiment on a trouvé
dans cet écosystème de centrale paris
l'accès à des réseaux le réseau peps
nous a permis d'avoir notre première
subvention et ensuite d'autres
subventions aussi lié à cet écosystème
paris saclay donc c'est grâce à eux
qu'on est là aujourd'hui
simplement le but évidemment pour nous
c'est de commercialiser nos produits
pour la fin d'année prochaine
donc des préventes à partir de partir du
printemps et une commercialisation il ya
des réseaux spécialisés à partir de la
fin de l'année prochaine et un gros coup
à noël c'est un achat qui est très
cadeaux
et si nous nous mettions tous au végétal
l'agriculture urbaine se développe sur
votre territoire un projet étonnant a
germé au sein du proto 2 104 habitants
étudiants chercheurs start up vous
pouvez tous venir cultivez votre jardin
mais comment ça marche tout de suite les
précisions de ronan james c'est le
responsable du poteau de 104
le cnam c'est un espace
d'expérimentation de tests qu'on a voulu
ouvrir à tout le monde dans un nouveau
lieu du protoss qui est à 7 terrasses
qui est juste à côté de l'yvette et on
se dit qu'on voulait pouvoir permettre à
tout le monde de pratiquer le végétal
que ce soit pour des start up
que ce soit pour des habitants des
étudiants ou des chercheurs de brasser
toutes ces communautés là autour du
végétal son histoire date un petit peu
puisque c'est un peu plus d'un an en
décembre 2014 ou en fait il ya un groupe
de designers d'architectes d'innovateur
assez large qui sont venus avec une idée
un peu folle de dire comment est ce
qu'on pourrait transformer le campus à
travers l'agriculture urbaine avec bien
sûr ce contexte de paris saclay qui est
un territoire avec beaucoup
d'agriculture et de nature et en même
temps des scientifiques et la ville
évidemment qu'ils apparaissent assez un
peu des trois piliers on pourrait dire
de l'agriculture urbaine et donc c'est à
dire comment est ce qu'on pourrait faire
ça c'était une séance de design fiction
comme les appelle ça c'est une
projection dans l'avenir de ce qui
pourrait être possible
donc petit à petit on a construit une
démarche sur cette question de à des
cultures urbaines sur le campus et en
juin 2000 2015 donner à annecy cote et
mathilde briançon nous rejoindre dans
l'équipe du projet pour pour le soutenir
et le mettre en place et en décembre
pour le quatrième atelier de
préfiguration on a fait un peu plus
grand que d'habitude en évitant une
dizaine d'acteurs de l'agriculture
urbaine qu'elle soit locale ou qu'elles
soient en dehors du territoire pour
expliquer ce que c'est convaincre par la
démonstration de ce que eux mêmes font
tous les jours
et puis aussi avoir une activité de peu
d'autocritique on pourrait dire à quoi
ça sert à quoi ça sert moins et on passe
à celui notamment avec le reste
un green là-bas paris saclay où
l'agriculture urbaine apparaissent la
clé on peut se demander pourquoi moi je
pense qu'il ya au moins deux raisons à
cela d'une part c'est de pouvoir
s'approprier la ville d'hakkari culture
et la nature donc rendre la ville peut
être un peu plus belle un peu moins
grise c'est assurément à ça on peut le
faire donc c'est un premier message vers
les habitants les acteurs de la ville de
prendre part à cette activité eux mêmes
l'autre aspect c'est le bas un peu comme
les fab lab ont démocratisé la
technologie est ce qu'on peut
démocratiser l'agriculture en tout cas
faire en sorte qu'on cultive soi même ce
qui nous fait plaisir ce qu ils disent
qu'ils ne semblent bons pour nous ce
sera peut-être pas dans les quantités
suffisantes mais au moins c'est une
pratique qu'on peut faire soi même et ça
c'est quelque chose qui est important
défendre une planète plus verte c'est le
credo de valérie masson-delmotte cette
climatologue citoyenne a participé à la
coop 21 elle été observatrice au sein du
groupe d'experts sur l'évolution du
climat
elle va nous faire part de son
expérience et nous explique surtout
comment l'université paris saclay
s'inscrit dans cette démarche
environnementale
j'ai été observatrice de la coop 21 au
titre des nations unies pour le groupe
d'experts sur l'évolution du climat
donc j'ai observé tout ce travail
délicat de négociations avec les
représentants des différents
gouvernements
il y avait également beaucoup d espace
de dialogue entre les chercheurs la
société civile le monde de l'entreprise
les organisations non gouvernementales
les représentants des différents pays
sur un certain nombre de sujets parce
que c'est aussi une occasion pour
transmettre nos connaissances vers le
monde politique où l'ensemble de la
société
donc au tour de l'université paris
saclay il ya beaucoup d'acteurs
scientifique des recherches portant sur
les causes du changement climatique sur
les scénarios d'évolution possible futur
et aussi sur les impacts du changement
climatique que ce soit sur les sociétés
humaines ou sur certains écosystèmes
on se structure avec la mise en place de
cette université dans le cadre en
particulier d'un département des
sciences de la planète et de l'univers
afin de répondre aux enjeux énergétiques
et climatiques qui ont été évoqués lors
de notamment lors de la cop 21 une
réponse opérationnelle et concrètes qui
est proposé dans le cadre de
l'aménagement du plateau de saclay et la
réalisation d'un réseau de chaleur et de
froid à base d'énergie géothermique
l'échelle de l'infrastructure et des
besoins permet d'accéder à une ressource
locale et une épuisable qui la nappe de
l'albien il s'agit donc d'un réseau de
chaleur et de froid à base d'énergie
géothermique
comment cela fonctionne il y à un forage
qui permet de puiser cette eau c'est
aussi recul dans un réseau géothermale
est ensuite réinjectée à nouveau dans la
nappe de l'albien de dire qu'on est sur
un circuit fermé
la solution technique proposée par
l'industriel permet d'atteindre une
haute performance énergétique et
environnementale l'énergie livrée sera
62 % renouvelable et les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre seront trois fois
inférieur à une solution conventionnelle
fonctionnant au gaz
la coop 21 ans a vraiment été une
réussite à la fois dans son organisation
et puis également dans l'accord de paris
donc c'est un accord universel qui va
être ouvert à ratification mais qui a
été approuvé par les représentants des
195 pays qui étaient présents c'est
probablement l'accord le plus ambitieux
qui pouvaient être obtenus au consensus
de l'ensemble des pays présents enfin
c'est une opération ambitieuse qui se
prépare au sein du quartier de l'école
polytechnique la première résidence
étudiante du campus paris saclay va voir
le jour
l'établissement d'aménagement public
paris saclay a donné son feu vert
330 logements de restaurants et 400 m²
de commerces
je vous laisse découvrir cette résidence
dans le cadre du développement du
plateau de paris saclay on assiste à
l'arrivée de nombreuses entreprises et
écoles et avec elle un besoin croissant
de logements pour des étudiants et des
apprentis résidences sociales de france
qui est une filiale du groupe 3f s'est
associé avec arpège une association qui
gère des résidences étudiantes et on a
répondu à un appel à candidature on a
été sélectionné et on a donc développé
ce projet avec dosage en architecture
une agence belge 51 une 4e et une agence
nantaise pour vous et grains d'orge et
l'idée du projet et le ps c'était qu'on
se dise que les logements étudiants on
et habite pas comme des logements
classiques mais on vit au sein d'un
campus avec tout ce que cela comprend
d'interaction le projet architectural de
l'opération il comprend trois bâtiments
on a deux petits bâtiment de deux
niveaux qui sont construits en béton
préfabriqué de couleur rouge assez
intense et le plus grand des bâtiments
qui à la fois le plus grand par sa
longueur et par sa hauteur reprend cette
idée de socle rouge en béton préfabriqué
sur lequel viennent se poser cinq
niveaux de logements en béton rose clair
on a trois entités principales dans
l'opération une partie logement étudiant
qui accueillera 330 étudiants ou
apprentis
on a proposé des espaces communs
qualitatif qui permettent d'être des
vrais lieux de rencontre le hall qui est
de taille
agréable des salles polyvalentes des
salles d'étude et dé la bri collective
la deuxième entité cd restaurant puisque
au sein même du bâtiment on aura deux
restaurants un restaurant universitaire
et un restaurant interentreprises
respectivement 2000 et 800 couverts et
enfin des locaux commerciaux dont la
nature reste à définir
en tout on construit plus de onze mille
mètres carrés en les spécificités de
cette opération c'est d'une part qu on
propose des colocations parce que c'est
une formule à laquelle on croit en
logements étudiants
donc outre des classiques studio qu'on
peut trouver habituellement on propose
des logements pour deux ou quatre
étudiants qui partagent une cuisine et
un séjour et l'autre spécificité c'est
justement d'avoir pensé les espaces
communs et les espaces de circulation
comme de véritables espaces de rencontre
et de convivialité
le projet doit être livré pour la
rentrée universitaire 2016 avec des
étudiants qui rentreront à partir de
septembre ce qui nous laisse sept petits
mois de chantier pour l'instant on est
dans les temps
et avant de nous quitter notre agenda
tous les événements à ne pas rater dans
les semaines qui viennent il y à déjà
ces deux enquêtes publiques qui débute
dans le quartier de l'école
polytechnique
c'est à partir du 1er février l'autre
concerne le quartier de corbeil ville
elle débute le 8 février pour le comité
de suivi des chantiers pour le quartier
de l'école polytechnique
rendez vous est pris le 22 février à
17h30 au plateau des projets de le paix
à paris saclay d'ici là ne manquez pas
le salon tech'innove qui se déroulera à
orly le 11 février
l'établissement public d'aménagement
paris saclay sera présent et animera un
atelier sur comment utiliser le
potentiel d'innovation des entreprises
du territoire pour faire la ville de
demain
voilà c'est fini pour aujourd'hui pour
plus d'informations je vous invite à
consulter notre site
le pap est ce point fr on se retrouve
très vite pour un nouveau numéro
et d'ici là n'oubliez pas utile et
là-bas